- ♫ The black one has
some poop in its butt ♫
♫ The black one has
- ♫ Puppy poop is like regular dog poop ♫
♫ Except it's smaller ♫
♫ And it comes from a cuter butt ♫
(cheerful music)
It is so hard to answer questions
while these dogs are here.
When Will was there,
it was my first year,
so I was still trying to figure out
where the bathrooms were.
- Yeah, you didn't find out.
- I never did.
I just, always just went where I stood.
- Guys, please.
(upbeat music)
I learned that Amy loves reading palms.
- Will, Annie, give me your palm.
I can read anybody's palm.
Life line, love line,
success, failure,
these are your kids.
The middle of your palm
talks about what you want.
The top of your hand
talks about what you have.
- It's a little obnoxious.
- I learned that Will,
Will drives one of those
recumbent bikes to work.
He likes to lean back,
that's how he gets everywhere.
(laughs)
With the flag.
- Arm workout.
- Yeah.
- Yep.
- It takes him a really
long time to get to set,
and he's gotten--
- But I'm in great shape.
- In quite a few accidents.
- Yep.
(upbeat music)
I feel like Leslie Knope.
- I think Leslie might win.
- I think she'd win.
- I just feel like she'd know,
she knows a little bit more.
- Buddy would just cry.
- Buddy has the size.
He might inadvertently hurt Leslie,
like, fall on her.
- Like, Of Mice and Men situation?
- Exactly.
(cheerful music)
- I think that the best highsch--
The yearbook quote would just be,
"Covfefe".
- Yeah, covfefe.
(cheerful music)
- Did you ever bring your child,
kids home a puppy?
- I did,
and then I had to take it away
like an hour later.
It turns out they didn't deserve it.
I'm gonna call this guy
Lazy Bones.
- Aww, Lazy Bones.
And I'll call this guy Good For Nothing.
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
- This is an awkward moment.
- That's-- Get a close up.
They're making out.
- [Amy] They're making out.
I guess it's when you try to--
- [Will] Yeah, that's an awkward moment.
- Do that,
and then your co-star's not ready for it.
- Right.
When you go to kiss them,
and then you--
After a couple kisses try to
kiss them in the private area.
- Yeah.
- That's an awkward moment.
Which is what just happened.
- This is--
These two puppies are re-enacting
a scene that Will and I did
that got cut for time.
It didn't test well.
- Didn't test well.
(upbeat music)
I really wish I hadn't gone back
for the last season of ER.
- That you had gone back?
- No, that I hadn't.
'Cause I had a great run
as Dr. Peter Willoughby
and they asked me to come
back for one more season
and it was done.
- This is our director.
- [Will] And his assistant director.
- [Amy] And his assistant director.
They always--
- They're having creative differences,
but it always comes out great.
(upbeat music)
- Gosh, what would I do?
I'd probably get on the subway
and just manspread as much as I could.
I'd take up so many seats.
- If I were Amy,
I would love to buy an economy ticket
on any airline.
And pretend like it was a king-sized bed.
(upbeat music)
- I can't concentrate.
There's too many puppies here.
- Does she run a pet
store now, by any chance?
- Yeah, she-- I don't know.
Let me think about something.
Umm she runs a pet store now
with puppies running around.
- Ron Burgundy
is on his sailboat right now.
My guy's so sweet.
- I know, these guys are so sweet.
You two are embarrassing me.
You're embarrassing your mother.
- See in our movie, The House,
we have a, you know,
it's all about gambling and casinos.
Should we bet money
on these puppies fighting
each other right now?
Oh that's illegal, right?
Okay, nevermind.
Scratch that.
We don't have to use it.
We can't use any of this.
- We can't.
We're not--
We didn't get a release for the puppies.
- We didn't get it.
The puppies are on strike.